[Music]
crisper the molecular scissors that shot
to fame in 2012 has revolutionized
biology because it makes it simpler and
cheaper for scientists to cut genomes
wherever they choose the power of CRISPR
lies in what happens after it makes a
cut theoretically the natural system
that repairs cuts can [ __ ]
disease-causing genes or scientists can
swap in new DNA potentially fixing say
the mutation that causes sickle cell
anemia recently several labs have
manipulated the CRISPR platform for
Diagnostics to simplify detection of
viruses or even tumors CRISPR complex
finds a targeted part of a genome with a
guide RNA the guide toes along an enzyme
from what's known as the castes family
that does the actual cutting buck-ass
enzymes come in many varieties after
they make the targeted cut some go into
a feeding frenzy and cut any
single-stranded nucleic acids nearby
these are the cast enzymes used in
detection systems imagine blood from a
patient suspected of having Zika
basically researchers could prep the
sample add all the necessary ingredients
and then spike it with a piece of
single-stranded DNA or RNA that has a
fluorescent reporter system attached to
it if CRISPR find Zika the casts enzyme
cuts the virus and cuts the molecule
holding the reporter which makes it
fluoresce
the latest versions of these systems
nicknamed Sherlock and detector have
shown that they simultaneously can find
several different viruses or mutations
associated with tumors the researchers
also have made progress on moving CRISPR
based detections to test strips similar
to what's used in pregnancy tests one
day they envisioned it may be possible
with just a drop of blood to have an
easy to read result that tells doctors
whether a patient has Zika virus or it's
close cousin dengue a multi-channel
strip may also reveal which type of
dengue
first genome editing now diagnostics
where will CRISPR take us next
[Music]
you